hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 2018 British American
Science Fiction and drama movie called
Anon
in the future people have to live in a
world where technology is developing
very fast and there is no privacy again
every person is implanted with an
augmented reality ocular device that
records everything they see and can
displace someone's detailed personal
information such as name age occupation
and many more Sal Friedland a detective
in this city is on his way to work while
exploring nearby people's personal
information at some point he crosses
paths with a mysterious girl later
called Anon whose personal information
is not displayed which makes him
confused as a detective Sal receives
complaints from other people and has the
permission to access people's memories
to solve or clarify related crimes one
of them is Dominic Ray whose son hasn't
returned his call Sal goes through the
ether the database where memories of all
people are being stored and finds the
footage of his son who just ended his
life by jumping off the building there's
also Alyssa igorian who claims that her
bracelet was stolen by a maid in the
hotel room he replaced the recording
from the maid's perspective showing that
she was doing his job did not steal
anything however after the woman leaves
it is revealed that Sao deliberately did
not show her what happened a minute
earlier the maid indeed stole the
bracelet and he decided not to show it
because she sold it to pay her rent Sal
also has the authority to decide whether
someone is guilty or innocent in a case
by assessing through their memories
a few moments later a man has just been
murdered and he directly heads over to
the crime scene another detective
Charlie sends the recording to sow and
he discovers that someone has been able
to murder off the Record by altering
with the victim's point of view the
perpetrator swaps his her point of view
with his her victim's point of view and
then kills him because of that the
detective couldn't identify the killer
as they have no proof at all Charlie
explains that there's also another case
where the victim's point of view got
hacked and killed in the exact same
method he adds that the killer might be
a woman but they cannot find her
information until now Sal tells his
partner the mysterious woman he saw
earlier in the street later that night
he tries to replay the memory of anon
while making love with his girlfriend
but the recording suddenly is deleted
realizing that Sal is thinking about
another woman the girl becomes upset and
leaves him immediately the next day the
detectives with the help of Lester who
is an I.T expert investigate the murder
case and discover that the man had a
mysterious guest before he was killed
but they cannot find any evidence of the
meeting after digging deeper into the
similar case they then conclude that all
victims hired someone with the expertise
to manipulate or delete some part of
their visual records that were either
humiliating or incriminating
Sal reveals that the description of the
Anon matches the description of the last
person to see the victim alive making
her their primary suspect it is also
revealed that Anon has the ability to
delete any recordings from every person
that sees her making her completely
anonymous
after work Sal plays the recording of
his son he then attempts to call his
ex-wife Kristen and reminds her that
tomorrow is their son's birthday she
tells him to stop remembering their son
as he has already died it is then
revealed that Kristen has married
another man who was unhappy with Sal
because he keeps calling her Sal is
upset and hangs up the call a few
moments later a murder case with the
same method occurs again this time the
victims were two girls whose Visions
were also hijacked after examining the
maids recording Sal realizes that the
Killer is still in the house and
attempts to seek out her unfortunately
Anon kills the guard and Sal chases
after her in the train station his
vision suddenly glitches and he gets hit
by the train later on the detectives
learned that the perpetrator wants to be
paid in cash which is the currency that
cannot be hacked that's why she has to
meet face to face with the client Sal
also real realizes that his vision was
altered when he was chasing after her
causing him to get hit by the train that
never existed to lure her out the
detectives planned to hire her and Sal
will act as bait he will go undercover
deliberately creating a false record as
a stockbroker who engages in an affair
with a prostitute and is afraid that his
fiance will find that out after that she
makes contact with Anon and asks her to
meet in person to delete the history
with the prostitute he brings her to his
apartment and the deletion process
begins while Lester is tracking and
monitoring her from the other room Sal
explains that he wants the prostitute
gone from his memory she deletes it
easily and also manages to alter the
timeline to fill the Gap Anon reveals
that she does not want to exist even as
someone else that's why she doesn't use
aliases and hides all her personal
information after the job is done Anon
takes the money and immediately leaves
saltras to chase after her but it's too
late
the next day the new tech specialist
Cyrus Freer is introduced to the team he
manages to hack into anon's vision and
they can now see what she is doing in
real time through her eyes Lester claims
that she has to be active and ether in
order for them to track her location she
eventually gets into The Ether and plays
A Memory of Jesper Nix a money-leading
art dealer who is doing business with
Max Keener who was previously known as a
forger Anon then deletes jesper's
meeting with the forger and replaces it
with him acting like he has discovered
the painting Jasper then attempts to
sell the fake painting to make profit
the detectives managed to trace all 12
proxies but the last one remains unknown
after monitoring a non for a day the
detectives still cannot Trace her
location and suddenly loses the
connection a few moments later NYX is
found dead killed by the same person
with the same method Joseph the bureau
commissioner thinks that the homicide
case is not a big deal because the
victims deserved it but Sal is against
it coming to a dead end Charlie suggests
Sal go undercover again to find more
information about Anon this time acting
as a man who buys drugs they meet again
in Sal's apartment and Anon deletes all
The Unwanted subjects and replaces it
with whatever Sal wants they begin to
develop a personal relationship and Anon
starts telling the detective her
personal problems after having fun in
bed she finally discovers Sal's true
identity and immediately leaves there
unfortunately while he attempts to go
after her he finds Lester has been
killed seemingly by her not long after a
non-called cell and threatens that she
will kill him if he tries to find her
since then Anon starts haunting Sal
tormenting him with his worst memories
such as being hit being chased by a dog
and a room full of rats it is also
revealed that his son was killed after
getting hit by a car the next day Sal
finds that all good memories related to
his family have been deleted by Anon he
immediately calls his ex-wife and asks
her to send the memories about their son
to him however Anon has also deleted all
of that in Kristen's mind suddenly Sal
sees a raging fire in the apartment he
pulls out his gun and Fires at random
Direction but soon he realizes that he
was just hallucinating as soon as the
hacker removes all the illusion he also
almost shoots one of his neighbors while
driving Anon Alters his vision as if
there are no cars at all on the road he
proceeds and suddenly there are a lot of
cars in the street causing him to hit
several of them a few moments later
while talking to Charlie an officer
shows up up telling them that Sal has
shot one of his neighbors he tries to
convince the others that the recording
has been manipulated and he has been set
up by the hacker but they reject the
explanation and because of that Charlie
decides to suspend him from the mission
and Sal is forced to stay home with
surveillance around the clock he then
reluctantly complies later that night
Sal pretends to sleep and secretly walks
out of the apartment knocking out the
man who is supposed to watch over him he
heads over to anon's apartment upon
arrival Anon reveals that someone is
killing her clients trying to make it
look like she killed them she shows him
her memory of the time Lester was killed
proving that it's not her who killed his
partner after that she escapes from the
apartment
a few moments later Charlie confronts
Sal and the detective is officially
relieved of all Duty the next day Anon
attempts to meet the detective and
distract all the officers guarding in
front of the apartment however the real
killer follows her and attempts to kill
Sal in his apartment Sal gets shot in
his stomach turns out that he is Cyrus
the newcomer I.T specialist in the
detective's team who has been obsessed
with a non for years killing anyone who
had had sex with her realizing that
Cyrus is seeing what he sees in real
time Sal attempts to shoot Cyrus and the
bullet hits him once they try to escape
from the apartment but Sal once again
blindfoldedly shoots him this time
shooting him to death Anon then walks
away from there as nothing has happened
at the end of the movie Sal gets his
good old memories back and needs a non
for the last time she reveals that she
breaks her life up into fraction of
seconds and randomly stores them in the
records of everyone else that's why she
is untraceable when asked why she
insists on hiding herself from the world
she answers that it is not because she
has something to hide but merely just
because she doesn't want to share
anything about her life to anyone
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching